last night President Donald Trump gave
an emergency oval office address about
the virus the speech confirmed two
things primarily Donald Trump is a liar
and Donald Trump is incompetent you
probably knew both of those things first
of all just to get the optics out of the
way for some reason Donald Trump's right
eye seemed almost completely swollen
shut during the entire nine minute
speech his breathing was also extremely
labored the left eye which was open
seemed red and odd so increasing
suspicions that Donald Trump himself may
be sick whether it's with the virus or
not we don't know that's the optics
let's now get to the substance which is
the most important thing most of the
nine minutes was Donald Trump either
bragging about how great he's done with
the virus or blaming other people for
anything that has hasn't gone the right
way I'm not even gonna play all of these
examples for you because they're
pointless and Stern in terms of actually
protecting ourselves but Donald Trump
said that his travel travel closures
from China were great now the truth is
even after he announced them which was
very late flight still continued flying
in from China for a while he said the
power of the United States to fight
pandemics is great it's almost like
military language like this is a
military battle we're going into he
bragged about authorizing eight billion
dollars way too late by the way after
denying for a while that we need to do
anything about this for a response and
then he also attacked the European Union
about how they didn't act as quickly as
he did they caused a lot of the cases
that we have here it's Europe's fault
let's look briefly at the Europe attack
and taking early intense action we have
seen dramatically fewer cases of the
virus in the United States that are now
present in Europe the European Union
failed to take the same precautions and
restrict travel from China and other
hotspots as a result a large number of
new clusters in the United States were
seated by travelers from Europe he also
used the number of cases here which we
know to be false to claim that we don't
have that many cases the reality of
course is we haven't been
thing because Donald Trump completely
bungled that as well then on the policy
stuff
what is Trump actually doing Trump was
either deceptive or clueless on almost
every single point Trump said travel
from Europe is now banned this was one
of the big points that he made after
consulting with our top government
health professionals I have decided to
take several strong but necessary
actions to protect the health and
well-being of all Americans to keep new
cases from entering our shores we will
be suspending all travel from Europe to
the United States for the next 30 days
now a lot of people thought wow okay I
mean it's a lot but this will stop
transmission to some degree we're
shutting down all travel to and from
Europe for everybody however not only is
the United Kingdom exempted meaning you
just have to get yourself from wherever
in Europe to the UK and then fly to the
United States presumably you'll be asked
about where you're coming from but again
that these are not failsafe methods more
importantly the ban does not apply to
u.s. citizens or residents and u.s.
citizens or residents aren't banned from
flying to Europe and then simply coming
back this is just foreign nationals who
aren't allowed to come to the United
States the statement making that clear
which was released after the fact by the
administration and again as Donald Trump
said you can also get exemptions Donald
from also during this address last night
said the European travel ban also
applies to trade and cargo that was just
not true the White House had to correct
that later and remember Trump was
reading all of this off of a
teleprompter these were not off-the-cuff
Mis statements from Donald Trump it was
on the prompter meaning either whoever
wrote the speech has absolutely no idea
what it is that's going on or they
decided let's just lie in order to make
this seem like something other than what
it is so you can argue about whether
this Europe thing is the right policy
but Trump presenting the policy one way
it's actually something completely
different immediately sending all sorts
of people into panic because they
misunderstood because of what Trump said
what the policy actually is another
example and this one is straight-up
insane Donald Trump
said during the address yesterday he met
with health insurance companies and they
are waiving all co-payments for
coronavirus treatments that's a big deal
if it's true listen to Donald Trump say
earlier this week I met with the leaders
of health insurance industry who have
agreed to waive all co-payments for
coronavirus treatments extend insurance
coverage to these treatments and to
prevent surprise medical billing so
there it is Trump says insurance
companies are waiving all co-payments
for coronavirus treatment Wow that's a
big deal that's a really good thing
turns out it's a complete and total lie
Donald Trump misstated it on national
television in front of the entire
country
we immediately afterwards heard from a
spokesperson for a hip a hip is a big
insurance health insurance company
lobbying group and they said no no we
are waiving co-pays on testing for the
virus
we are not waiving co-pays or
coinsurance or deductible requirements
for treatment this is something Trump
read off of a teleprompter and it was
not true you can get tested without a
copay
even though suppose we were told the
tests weren't gonna cost the end-user
anything anyway I don't even know why we
need that from insurance companies but
you have to often be tested for other
things first rule them out before you
can be tested for kovat if you do have
the virus and you need treatment you
will have to pay your co-pays you will
have to pay your coinsurance if you have
it if you first have to meet your annual
deductible you will have to meet it that
can be thousands of dollars for many
many people so in short a speech about
something which Trump claimed is no big
deal but it still requires an emergency
9:00 p.m. Eastern Time speech to the
country riddled with lies and deception
and incompetence Trump also promised
some financial relief to people who are
either sick or quarantined or caring for
people who are also announced as small
business association loans add interest
to businesses those policies would
actually be good if they happen but
Trump lied his way through the entire
speech Trump also said he's proposing
the
payroll tax cut through the end of the
year if that happens that could take a
while and Trump is refusing to meet with
Nancy Pelosi whose help he needs in
order to get that done we'll talk about
that a little bit later but the the sort
of the icing on the cake on a rotten
cake that is riddled with infections you
know the icing on the cake is to claim
insurance companies are waiving
treatment co-payments when they're not
that actually would be a really big deal
if they were doing it but it is not true
and Trump you know he takes the
political benefit of saying it most of
the country probably never hears the
correction that was untrue where were
the fact checkers how does so much
misinformation get into a teleprompter
speech I don't know the president's own
speech was riddled with fake news this
episode is sponsored by blue chew one of
the things I make a priority on the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off and blue shoe can increase
performance and give you that extra
confidence you may be looking for blue
to calm blue like the color blue is the
first chewable with the same
fda-approved ingredient as in Viagra and
Cialis it can be taken day or night even
on a full stomach since it's chewable it
works twice as fast as a pill whenever
the opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue two prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue
shoe com get your first shipment free
when you use our promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma n pages $5 shipping
that's blue2 dot-com promo code Pakman
to try it totally free blue chew is the
better cheaper faster choice and we
thank them for sponsoring the David
Pakman show